I have a major swamp filling alert for
you it's now not just Donald Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner who's going to
be working in the Trump administration
you might remember that Donald Trump's
new Attorney General is William Barr
William bar has a son-in-law named Tyler
McGehee he has been appointed to the
White House legal office and this is
just a swamp filling Red Alert Donald
Trump's attorney General William Bar
consider is going to be supervising the
Trump Russia investigation his
son-in-law might now be representing
Trump in regard to that Trump Russia
probe now what we're told so far is that
Tyler McGehee has not been assigned
specifically to that task but he's
working alongside in the White House
legal office lawyers who are on the
opposing side of his own father-in-law
the Attorney General William bar and
every indication is that this is exactly
the type of conflict of interest that
has more or less gone unpunished in the
Trump administration yes Jeff Sessions
ended up having to recuse himself as
Attorney General on Trump Russia matters
but when we talk about these
circumstances we don't even need to
prove an actual conflict of interest
like it doesn't actually matter whether
McGehee is assigned to be opposite his
father-in-law in this particular case
the mere appearance of a conflict of
interest is all we need to be able to
determine this simply can't be just
because they can't prove that something
in particular was done that's a conflict
having the Attorney General supervising
a probe on the opposite side of a lawyer
possibly representing the subject when
that lawyer happens to be your
son-in-law is obviously the apparent
conflict of interest and thus that's all
we really need to know it might manifest
in a specific way or it might not that
doesn't matter this is a conflict and I
wish that media outlets would stop
playing coy about this possible
appearance of a
hypothetical conflict we've talked
before Pat about when Trump lies call it
a lie it's not a mischaracterization
we've talked about how some media
outlets for legal reasons hesitate to
say it's a lie
when it comes to this just say it is
actually a conflict of interest yeah and
I really don't think that this story
will go anywhere because in the early
days of the Trump administration there
were some talk about the conflict of
interest of Trump having his son-in-law
Darren Kushner and his daughter Ivanka
Trump in the administration you know
because of the ties to the family
business of course but ultimately they
didn't go anywhere they're both still
working in the White House so if there
wasn't that much outrage about that
conflict I don't see one happening about
William bar son-in-law absolutely not
and this is you know this by itself
would have been a scandal for several
days on all right wing media if it had
taken place under President Barack Obama
and not only is it not going to have
consequences in the Trump administration
it barely even rates even a lot of left
wing shows haven't been talking about it
some because they know it's just not
going to go anywhere we've been
following the swamp filling despite
promises of swamp draining and so I
think it's an important story to tell
you about but this is yet another I mean
are we talking about hundreds of
instances now of misdeeds that would
have been scandals for Barack Obama that
go completely unpunished under the Trump
administration disgusting cronyism a
second-order nepotism I guess we would
say right it's not Trump's family member
but it's his Attorney General's family
member
disgusting and the only solution is to
vote them out because it is
extraordinarily unlikely there will be
any consequences today's show is made
possible in part by Sun basket giving
everybody in our audience 60% off their
first box when you go to get Sun basket
calms slash Pakman you'll get six
dinners delivered to your door for just
twenty eight dollars son basket is a
meal kit service that brings fresh
ingredients for ready to cook recipes
right to your home but what separates
Sun basket from other meal plan services
is Sun baskets
eco-friendly food eco-friendly packaging
their commitment to organic ingredients
and their ability to fit almost any kind
of diet whether it's low-carb
gluten-free paleo vegetarian or vegan
pescetarian Mediterranean Sun basket
also has amazing meal plans even if you
don't have dietary restrictions just
choose what kind of meal plan you want
the number of recipes you want to
receive each week and son basket lets
you choose which individual recipes you
get before they're sent to you so you're
always getting something you love and
the recipes change every week you can
even choose when the meals show up at
your home you can skip weeks which is
also really convenient
everything arrives totally fresh all the
ingredients are pre measured so cooking
is a breeze and all of the recipes take
less than 30 minutes to make so it's
perfect for people with busy lives sign
up for affordable tasty healthy organic
eco friendly recipes brought straight to
your home ready to cook and save 60% off
your first week of meals when you go to
get Sun basket dot-com slash Pakman six
dinners delivered to your door for just
28 bucks I've put a link right
underneath this video